JENNIFER THOMAS: So
far we've learned
that a scalable app
can gracefully handle
peaks and dips in traffic.
But each application has
its own infrastructure
and scaling requirements.
Let's take a look at how Critter
Junction launched a new app
and how they chose
where to run it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With more users than ever
and with their new immutable
infrastructure, Critter
Junction was in a great place
to launch a new app.
They wanted to launch
a companion game that
used the same database but
lets you build and share
house layouts using
your inventory,
codenamed The Layout App.
With a new app launch,
scale and unpredictability
is always a big challenge.
You may never know
exactly how many players
will show up on launch day.
They needed to find a
solution on Google Cloud that
could automatically
handle any amount of load.
The team already knew
they wanted a layout app
to scale independently
from their web servers,
but they have lots of options.
One solution is to
run The Layout App
on a separate set of VMs.
Using Google's
Global Load Balancer,
you can send traffic to backend
managed instance groups.
These can automatically scale
multiple identical machines
based on metrics
like CPU utilization.
So they could easily handle
more traffic across regions.
But it turned out
The Layout App didn't
need to run with access
to the operating system.
And the team wanted their apps
to be lightweight and portable
across environments.
So they decided to
containerize it.
Containers are basically
an isolated package
for just running an application.
It's a great way to
build a cloud-native app,
but you still need to serve it.
Two choices for
serving containers
would be managed instance groups
running container-optimized OS
or Google Kubernetes Engines.
Both solutions automatically
scale up as demand increases,
adding new machines as
needed, and removing them
when demand is low.
This can increase the
availability at peak times
while keeping your
costs manageable.
Either would work
to run their app
and meet their
unpredictable scaling needs,
but the team wanted
further abstraction
from the infrastructure.
They decided they didn't
want upfront provisioning
and wanted the ability to
scale down to zero resources.
The next step was to
look at serverless tech.
These technologies almost
completely abstract away
the infrastructure
and orchestration.
Unlike the previous
options, these
handle automatic
resource scaling
with virtually no configuration
or server provisioning.
Serverless mainly keys in
on running your application
so you can focus on your code.
Google Cloud has three main
options for running serverless.
First up, Cloud Functions
is great for snippets
of code and small,
single-purpose applications.
Functions scale by creating
new instances as demand rises.
And each function
handles a single request.
You can scale down
to zero and limit
the maximum number of
instances for full flexibility.
It's perfect for gluing together
different cloud services
like calling an API
based on a schedule
or sending notifications.
But it was too simple for
running The Layout App, so they
looked to App Engine,
which offers the ability
to run containers and
custom web applications
in a serverless way,
automatically creating
and shutting down instances
as traffic fluctuates.
You can configure the
settings for automatic scaling
based on your app's needs.
For example,
scaling can be based
on CPU utilization,
throughput utilization,
or maximum concurrent requests.
This could run their
containerized app
without a problem.
But the team wanted
to make sure they
could run their app in
multiple clouds down the road
and didn't want to re-architect.
Finally, there's
Cloud Run, which
is built on a project
called Knative.
Knative is all about serverless
running of containers
on top of Kubernetes.
But with Cloud Run, all
the Kubernetes action
is taking care of
behind the scenes.
Each deployment is
automatically scaled
to the number of
instances needed to handle
all incoming requests.
And it can scale from zero to
your specified max instances.
Because the app team
expected traffic spikes,
Cloud Run let them keep
some idle instances
to minimize cold starts.
And if they wanted to
bring in multiple clouds,
they could use the same
application and just
leverage Knative.
Given their needs for container
portability, fast scaling,
and minimal
infrastructure overhead,
the team decided on
Cloud Run and was
able to launch faster than
they thought possible.
While each option has
auto-scaling capabilities built
in, you can decide
which of these solutions
works best for the
requirements of your app.
Plus, you can use different
solutions for different apps,
giving you the power
to choose and scale.
Stay tuned to find out what's
in store for Critter Junction.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]